Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Pablo Neruda publicó su primera
colección de poemas a los 19 años.
A lo largo de su vida, ganó
el Premio Nobel de Literatura,
rescató 2000 refugiados,
pasó tres años en exilio político
y fue candidato a la presidencia de Chile.
Romántico y revolucionario,
Neruda fue uno de los poetas
más célebres del siglo XX,
pero también uno de
los más accesibles y controvertidos.
Originalmente escritos en español,
en sus poemas se emplea lenguaje directo
y se relatan experiencias cotidianas
para crear un efecto perdurable.
Neruda fue bautizado como
Ricardo Eliécer Neftalí Reyes Basoalto
en un pequeño pueblo de Chile en 1904.
Su padre no quería que fuera poeta,
por lo que a los 16 comenzó a escribir
bajo el pseudónimo de "Pablo Neruda".
Los poemas de su colección "Veinte poemas
de amor y una canción desesperada"
eran tiernos y perceptivos,
a la vez que iluminaban las sutilezas
del amor y el encantamiento.
En "Poema VI", por ejemplo, escribe:
"Tu recuerdo es de luz,
de humo, de estanque en calma!
Más allá de tus ojos
ardían los crepúsculos".
Posteriormente, centró su poesía
en la apreciación de objetos cotidianos.
Muchos de los 225 poemas cortos
de su colección "Odas elementales"
se destinan a la clasificación
de los pequeños objetos,
aparentemente insignificantes,
que nos rodean:
desde un par de cordones a una sandía.
Una cebolla es "más hermosa
que un ave de plumas cegadoras",
y un atún en el mercado
es una "bala del profundo océano,
proyectil natatorio, te vi, muerto".
A pesar de sus primeros éxitos literarios,
Neruda tuvo dificultades económicas,
por lo que aceptó
varios trabajos diplomáticos
en lugares como Birmania,
Indonesia, Singapur y España.
En 1936, mientras Neruda trabajaba
en el consulado de Madrid,
estalló la guerra civil
y el gobierno fue derrocado
por una dictadura militar fascista.
Neruda organizó la evacuación
de refugiados, desde España a Chile,
salvando así a 2000 personas.
Durante 20 años,
Neruda registró
sus experiencias en el extranjero
en una colección de poemas
de tres volúmenes
titulada "Residencia en la Tierra".
Muchos de estos poemas
eran experimentales y surrealistas:
combinaban paisajes épicos,
temáticas de lo supernatural y añoranzas
con discusiones sobre disputas políticas
y la responsabilidad del poeta
de expresarse en contra de la injusticia.
En "Explico algunas cosas",
se detiene en detalles hechizadores
de la destrucción
de la guerra civil de España.
Por el resto de su vida,
Neruda permaneció comprometido
con sus ideales revolucionarios.
Debido a su posición política,
estuvo varios años exiliado
hasta 1952, cuando pudo regresar a Chile.
Durante sus años de exilio,
publicó su influyente "Canto General".
Aquí, intenta contar la historia de
toda América Latina a través de su poesía,
describiendo todo,
desde la flora y la fauna,
hasta las políticas y las guerras.
Pero principalmente
homenajea a la gente común,
responsable de los logros
de la civilización.
A pesar de que continuó viajando,
tras regresar del exilio
Neruda vivió el resto de su vida en Chile.
En 1970, a los 66 años,
Neruda fue candidato
a la presidencia de Chile,
pero renunció en favor
de Salvador Allende,
tras lo cual se convirtió en su consejero.
Pero en 1973
Allende fue derrocado tras el golpe
militar del General Augusto Pinochet.
Neruda murió en el hospital
unas semanas después.
Debido a que esto se dio
tan pocos días después del golpe,
se rumoreaba que había muerto de tristeza,
y hasta se decía que había sido asesinado.
Pero el hospital registró
que la causa de muerte era cáncer.
Hoy día, se recitan líneas de Neruda
en marchas y protestas de todo el mundo.
Así como su vida misma,
los poemas de Neruda conectaban
el romance con la revolución
al enfatizar los momentos cotidianos
por los que vale la pena luchar.